I feel so privileged to come back to
whatta Stanford
this year is the 20th reunion period and
right after this lecture I have to go to
the business school to have a liquid
preference function with all my
classmates so this is my last assignment
for before the liquid preference
function bear with me that so today's
topic is nano electronics in Japan and
Ti a how many of you are the engineering
screw school get backgrounds okay how
many of you are industry people you
interested business people business
sectors I see okay well today I'll speak
to to the fish how to swim so it's some
of the issues that i'm going to address
is easy stuff for you but boo bear with
needle that i'm a government official
i'm now a electrical engineer myself but
I've been working in the innovation
system for 25 years so I know a little
bit about innovation system as richard
has mentioned about WPI this job done
undertaking about Tia you know the open
consortium is a is the first very
important task for Japan trying to take
a very important task at that time of
the year the change from the old type of
Industry Relations to a new type of
Industry relationship so what do you
have a security hold on something's
going on
I'm sorry I'm not used to this gadget
here is some cut something going on in
the LSC exactly let's see I need
technical assistance probably operator
can you seems to be some kind of warning
here kisses yeah probably need to turn
it off or maybe security oh maybe
internet no response okay I just turn it
off yes okay right okay thank you so
when I was born 1961 computer was like
this one company making every components
mainframe was manufactured by one
electronic manufacturer the manufacturer
fabricated everything Oh wafer devices
circuit boards systems operating system
everything one manufacturer produce all
components but today smartphone is one
of the computer device for today you
have lots of different devices modules
and different industry behind it well I
want to talk about the decline of
Japanese electronic products the return
of sales of top five Japanese electronic
companies have dropped almost fifty
percent in over past 20 years the drop
of Japanese share this is a market share
here of Durant's panels a DVD player car
navigation system the drop the decline
of Japanese market share of these
components have become more and more
steep over the years this is due to the
horizontal division of labor which was
easily available in many of those
digital products and specification of
parts and modules
game standardized and this led product
commoditized faster this is a global
market share of semiconductor industry
as you can see the this is the red is
Japanese this one's us and these are
Europeans and agents now the Japanese
have grown and here near around nineteen
fifty eighty five there was a severe
discussion of Japan us semiconductor
negotiation and this is 1990 early 1990s
the US has overtaken Japan and since
then japan japanese share has been
declining how much of the japanese peak
was dram here yeah do you think that's
mostly dram or and basically you're also
seeing a shift in kinds of chips yes
there are shifts and kinds of chips but
the most of them i would say the drm
uh-huh and then after 1983 the Japanese
done nine companies continue to drop the
market share oh I'm sorry in 1987 global
top three companies somewhere around
here or Japanese companies but after
1993 the Japanese companies continue to
drop their market share and and this is
the current figure 2012 top 5 or non
Japanese and Korean and South townies
companies are increasing their market
share the ultimate scaling and mass
production the cutting edge rd on LSI
foresees that technology generation of
sub 10 nanometer design rule will come
in less than a decade you probably know
about the Moores theory and it will hit
the physical limit probably within that
10-year
and transition to a large-scale wafer
process is no longer an event of the
distant future and so this led to a rd
on mass production of ultimately scaled
LS eyes requiring a huge investment rd
risk is too high for any single company
to take you probably know about the alt
ultraviolet equipments these costs more
than 1 billion dollars the european
companies are fabricating those things
the huge machines now tough time for
japanese semiconductor industry
traditionally japanese companies were
good at what we call Surya assay which
means adjusting and integration of
downstream technology with upstream
technology usually took place in one
company this was made possible by
vertical alliance or in-house vertical
alliance product line Surya hace was
useful in the tacit knowledge transfer
of each value chain and could be
sophisticatedly integrated it was a
state of art procedure but it took time
and effort to have the real integration
today's electronics industry demand
standard standardized specification of
device and module of high quality in
short time in short span of time thus it
requires the decision of large equipment
investment hence needs a high volume
output in very short time period in
addition to that in recent years are the
downstream for example the application
software or networking those kind of
value chain is sucking up mar
for investment in semiconductors so
these led to downfall of Japanese
semiconductors in current market
business trend and atmosphere they're
just not fast enough even though they
did really good company internal right
adjustments and so forth yes as I
mentioned the equipment's for the for
those modules you know are so high
priced highly priced and that you need
to have a quick recovery because the
speed is very fast speed of innovation
is very fast and the equipment being so
expensive you need to sell a more volume
so high throughput so you need have a
fast decision on large equipment
investment and recoup it in a very short
time which is not fit to 30 sec kind of
stuff because it takes a longer time for
adjusting and you need to have a
standard I and which to do it doesn't
require a standardization because it's
not modules it's it's Owens in-house or
vertically integrated when when the
business environment is more modular and
everything becoming standardized and
specification became being standardized
this serious ethical you know business
practice is no longer applicable now
compounded with that there was a
deadlock of Japanese economic industry
and as I mentioned before each
technology of different value chain has
become more and more complicated and and
become more less independent
proposal by the Japanese business
Federation there is a promotion of
Japanese new deal and the CEO and CN
which is called the Council of
competitiveness they issue the
realization of environment harmonized
ubiquitous society and the large-scale
budget by meti ministry of export
Economy Trade and Industry and mixed
large-scale government funding was
poured in to the rd of new type of open
innovation now if you consider the open
innovation worldwide we already have we
also have other countries conducting an
open innovation in this technology field
imac in belgium minitec in france and
here in states the IBM and New York
State is running this albany nanotech
center and those blue ones are for the
power conductors freedom a North
Carolina they're mainly the contractors
of the DoD dot Park kind of stuff you
have ecp and CPS Japan has established
this tia nano which is the also open
innovation system both in the nanotech
nano electronics and pie electronics
this is the the Tiana know and the
members Kayden ran the the Japanese
business Federation AISD nince National
Institute of materials University of
scuba and kk high energy physics
institution what quedarnos okay okay so
it's a big industry Federation that
really represents kind of business
interests in Japan
Oh generally of large corporations and
so that's one of the industry
participants in this consortium a is
tease the now a kind of set of national
laboratories that are all under the
umbrella of the Ministry of Internal
economy trade in nutrition treaty nims
is specific to material science it's
also basically money from Nettie right
next next okay so that's education money
but its material science then you've got
University of scuba which is a national
university in japan and finally kek is
the high energy physics National
Research Center they have good particle
accelerators there and they have my PF
the SNF photo factory which is used for
the nano l charm nanodevice scoping yeah
i'm very things people were lying in
this arena now scuba you probably
haven't heard about it scuba scuba is a
city it's a it's a artificial city I it
wasn't there it's it's a merger of three
villages and distance from 60 kilometers
from Tokyo and 90 kilometers from Narita
Airport population is about 210,000
researcher about roughly 20,000
including various kinds of researchers
foreign residents 7032 nationals and 32
National Laboratories and 300 research
institutions the cabinet of Japan has
decided to create this science city
Tsukuba 50 years ago and concentrated
all those national institutions in this
little town scuba and they took 26
billion dollars for investment for the
construction of this city
this is in a sense very unique that the
government has created as high spark
this is really the model a lot of later
science parts I think she knew probably
modeled itself on Scoob Oh a little bit
not quite okay now let me show you the
videos for that nanotechnology research
and development requires a variety of
instruments and many people who have the
relevant expertise and skills this is
why many countries have attempted to
establish a global center for
nanotechnology that combined research
institutes and private companies to
stimulate personal contacts and
information exchange to achieve
innovations
the desire to create a global Center for
nanotechnology in Japan has been the
motivation for the establishment of the
scuba innovation arena also known as Tia
nano
scuba sign city in Ibaraki prefecture
this is one of the largest academic
cities in the world where as many as
12,000 researchers are working in over
300 research institutes a number of the
world's leading nanotechnology research
facilities are found here this is
therefore the best location in Japan for
a global center for nanotechnology
the national institute of advanced
industrial science and technology the
national institute for materials science
and the university of scuba all located
in scuba science city where instrumental
in creating in 2009 a global center for
nanotechnology called the scuba
innovation arena T&A no tiene dos logo
symbolizes the large arena formed by the
three institutes for close collaboration
you are now going to see the individual
facilities of T&A no these are the three
core infrastructures of T enano the
nanotech open user facilities the Nano
device research foundry and the
networking school of nanotechnology
first you will see the major facilities
in the nanotech open user facilities
this is an ultra high magnetic field NMR
with the strongest magnetic field in
Japan which is also one of the highest
in the world
it is an aggregation of six NMR
spectrometers that as a whole are
indispensable tools for the structural
analysis of substances ranging from
proteins to solid materials this is the
electron microscope in the high voltage
electron microscopy station this
microscope has the highest level of
performance and is a powerful instrument
for the examination and evaluation of
nanotech materials the Nano processing
facility has a number of advanced
apparatuses for nano processing and
measurement the facility is available
for research and development by visiting
researchers in various fields it also
provides human resource developments
this positron probe micro analyzer makes
it possible to observe defects at the
atomic or nanometer level in samples
this exemplifies the outcome of
activities for the development of new
measurement apparatus
we proceed now to the major facilities
in the nano device research foundry
this super clean room with the floor
area of 4,500 square meters is one of
the largest clean rooms for research in
the world an integrated device
demonstration and evaluation line
permits the fabrication of integrated
circuits with a circuit line width of
forty five nanometers on wafers with a
diameter of 300 millimeters you can see
now that the N MEMS foundry consists of
a 650 square meter clean room in which
nano processing apparatuses for nano
processing and evaluating of MEMS have
been installed the foundry provides a
continuous operation for the design test
model manufacture and mass production of
MEMS the advanced power electronics
Research Center allows operations to
carry out the entire process of the test
manufacture demonstration and evaluation
of silicon carbide based power devices
next we look at the networking school of
nanotechnology
education is an indispensable part of
the global center for nanotechnology the
University of scuba has been the hub of
a nationwide consortium of relevant
institutes in an attempt to establish
Tian a no networking schools
we have seen the extensive core
infrastructure of T enano these
facilities are open to all current and
future participants t enano has already
started original R&D projects utilizing
its core infrastructure 6 core research
domains have been established we are
preparing an overview of the projects
that will exemplify the possibilities
that t enano has to offer to researchers
the nano electronics domain utilizes the
super clean room for developing lsis
with very low power consumption
nano-sized new materials and structures
as well as new principles should
generate IT equipment with low power
consumption this will help create the
basic technology required in a
low-carbon society
the power electronics domain involves
the development of silicon carbide based
power devices for high-efficiency
silicon carbide power devices which have
a far higher performance than
conventional power devices are
approaching the stage of
commercialization
Oh
the N MEMS domain based on the N MEMS
foundry aims at mass producing MEMS and
integrating them into semiconductor
circuits the integration of various MEMS
into a single chip will find many
applications such as environmental
measurement or electric power monitoring
this will be an important technology in
a society of ubiquitous information the
purpose of the carbon nanotubes domain
is to develop an efficient technology
for the mass production of carbon
nanotubes the super growth method has
succeeded in obtaining a catalytic
efficiency that is several hundred times
that of the conventional techniques the
development of applications for carbon
nanotubes is proceeding concurrently
the Nano green domain is developing new
devices that may be useful in a
low-carbon society including solar cell
photocatalysis secondary cell fuel cell
and so on it is expected that
computational science and experimental
techniques will ensure a better
understanding of the operating
mechanisms of these devices and
improvements in efficiency
the target of the nano material safety
domain is the evaluation of methods
regarding the safety of nanomaterials a
risk assessment report for nanomaterials
was published in 2009 the domain is also
expected to serve as an information
center on the safety of nanotechnology
additional core domains may of course be
established by other researchers indeed
the definition of Tia nanos research
domains depends on the interest of the
participating researchers
we will now present historical overview
of the establishment and I have to talk
about the history now okay so this is
facts and figures of TN a know you have
the project scale is about 25 billion
Japanese yen per year an accumulation in
76 and in the five-year term we're
envisioning 100 billion Japanese yen we
want to have the the increase of public
funding and private funding currently it
it's eighty-five percent is public
funded national governmental programs
running but we're increasing more of the
private consortium private standalone
con salsa and twenty six percent I mean
there are 26 number of projects ongoing
each projects having its own consortium
number of industries partners about 128
and we are expecting to have it more
than 300 and here's a the figures with
regards to foreign participants it's
still very low and we want to increase
this number now this is tears vision of
future said as you have seen in the
video clip we're looking into super low
power technology basis for an Internet
of Things sorry this is in Japanese but
the core technology is here and it goes
on to photonics to these are the rd
super clean yes Ser stands for super
premium this is where all those are
we r DS happening immense and silicon's
and photonics we will have a green of
car sensing this is these are the
current business smartphones Aereo Gary
here is green IT s390 here and then down
south is network connectivity I don't
know class yes and that and in the
future we're looking into ubiquitous
networking and which will create green
by ID agriculture energy management
system health care and civilian systems
and infrastructure surveillance systems
all conducted under cloud computing and
we're looking into battery less mobile
communication for security health care
energy management but realist well I
would say one let's say one battery cell
for our computer or no batteries except
for the the solar panels and was small
smaller and the civilian assistance for
example I don't know so so let's let's
power okay now good gree green and ICT
is required for sustainable ICT society
currently we're using the internet above
about in year two thousand six 637 gig
of GP your GP PS and then in 20-25 it
will have 190 times more which would
help mean that you have five point two
times more of the energy consumption
which will lead into 240 billion
kilowatt hour which means that ICT
system will consume twenty percent of
total domestic electric power generation
which is a huge amount of energy so the
key issue of green nanotechnology is is
to downsize the energy consumption the
CPU the i/o and the memory portion all
all of each to be downsizing energy so
that you have least one percent of the
pod reduction let me explain these are
national projects that are being here in
this 55 Ministry of Economy Trade and
Industry national projects plus one
ministry of education national projects
and so they're all addressing green
technologies and ICT yes and each of
these projects have different consortium
members so different industries be it
horizontal or vertical I'll talk about
later that's a lot of money in these
projects and they're using the T enano
right yes ya know for the to conduct the
those projects this is basically
government funded projects now you will
see all those I think the time is
running out so I'll skip some of those
slides but it'll be handed out to you
those are some of the this is thien a no
facilities this super green room by the
way is going to be open for easier use
by web web based application and out of
that and at the very end and while
you're changing slides will post these
slides on our Asia stanford.edu website
will be able to see it from the course
page there yeah this is the the
methodology sistance and thus you have
high mob mobility channel CMOS and low
voltage operation rd
back end of line post silicon you know
the germanium it included CMOS
technology new materials and device for
low-power nanotech nanoelectronics you
know and this is back in here but not
all ordinary back end it has this atomic
switch to have more complicated device
here and we have new materials and also
quantum mechanism for the memory that
vote non-volatile memory and new
materials and device will open analytics
here again the carbon nanotubes have
been used and photonics used for the
transmission silicon photonics for low
power and high-speed interconnect now
other area you've heard about the PI
electronics in the video silicon carbide
is our main target of pi electrons in
japan now we have already developed a
motive of the the inverters see this is
the the green room here and then device
and then i have a trial modules and
parts and goes into systems see there
are different kinds of company being
involves it's there's a vertical I&C
within the this t pack that scuba power
electronic constellation reaches the
consortium which i will show you here
you have private companies of different
sources different value chain coming
together in ice ice being host of
innovation and you have universities and
public institutions into you know having
exchanges with iced to have an opening
innovation here no government money is
funded here and these are the
corporation that is involved in the
kenosha as you can see the different
kinds of corporations Toyota being here
and some like Torah it's is a material
company Tokyo electron is the you know
the
the equipment for some company now pie
electronics has a well this is tech
issue once again we are on the this
stage of first generation and targeted
at this power density but we have three
knows of I mean vectors of a research
and development each having different
consortium and the third generation is
looking into very high power density
which will be used for smokers etc and
the second generation used for railways
now time's running out so these are
carbon nanotubes you can see the the
slides later the Nano green which is
undertaking in names these are basically
the batteries solar batteries and
companies involved notice that you have
samsung here the de foreign company is
also involved in this nano green and
ponds OSHA skip this and MEMS don't have
much time for that now number two that
tight on time we go 5 30 0 5 30 ok I
thought you wanted 30 minutes to do that
it's true ok all right ok let me focus
here on the school of nanotechnology it
is very important that research and
development will take care of human
resource development and the University
of scuba is becoming a vehicle for
introducing many of the the education
side and bringing in students into this
consortium into this tia arena and many
of the students get degrees utilizing
those facilities and before pas stock
graduate school activities how do the
students actually go out there just
internships and the companies or are
they really working in the university
lab under a professor
but with government money different
modes not in the government projects
that I mentioned here there are the
students don't go into those things
normally but for example we have summer
schools for nano power electronics
nanoelectronics carbonyl turns all those
kinds of things and also the names one
of the institution actually runs the the
Graduate School one course of graduate
school per se and 54 researchers from
AISD are participating in the graduate
course of scuba University and you also
have other universities joining in to
Tacuba a through Tsukuba to our
institutions for internships sometimes
and also the the graduate works the
doctoral works so as a conclusion
Japanese semiconductor industries in a
very downfall as you have seen but Tia
open open R&D center for new nano tech
innovation is there to try to bring up a
new architectural innovation and which
will nullify this game plan as of today
and create a new game plan for a new
architecture architecture innovation for
new products super low power i T is the
key which we will create various new
values of future society and innovation
for super low power idea technology
which we're aiming at requires the
integration of diverse industry players
as I mentioned there are different kinds
and different players both bottom you
know material sciences and do the and
the user side like railways or even
accelerator front companies or
various kinds of software application as
well so you didn't require integration
of diverse industry players
collaboration among cooperation in
pre-competitive phase at the innovation
hub AISD idea but as it becomes more
competitive it's very difficult to
control each console sure has each
separate rules for the inventions and
also IP patterns know that I can give
you more detail about that but sorry
we're almost near time collaboration
between innovation hub and academia for
future technology resource and also
future human resource is very critical
that's why I'm asking the no I'm burn
all over the world and together with the
scientists to enlarge the scientific
base in the academia vase in a basic
science phase so that we can bring in
more of the new ideas into the into this
hub and to have rd or the more further a
future technology development and this
is the last slide and recent
advertisement I mentioned that there the
the facilities like super super clean
room is open for use but we have made it
more available to everybody in the world
open an easy utilization method of the
facilities it's web-based application
method and no joint rd agreement
necessary and intellectual property
basically belongs to prime to the to the
user strict confidentiality and ice the
technical assistance services being
available on the fee basis and there's
american company koe Te I and it has its
subsidiary
we who know our facility very well can
do the consulting work for usage if
you're interested that's one way of
doing utilizing our facility and through
the consultant so that's about it or
your comment thank you very much do some
Q&A so I before we do cute i want to
point out that professional yoshi onishi
here at Stanford is a silly exposure of
this tu mano so if you see some things
in that last slide about you know users
owning the IP and so forth some of its
kind of similar to what we're doing in
the Stanford nanofabrication facility
and there may be a you know some similar
ideas floating around now but I really
do want to point out that this is really
different from the whole way it used to
be in Japan yeah it used to be you would
not have industry and university and
government collaborating in anything
like this and the idea of having you
know universities doing training
programs in an organization a location
that is basically funded through a
different ministry now wouldn't happen I
want to ask you you mentioned these
other global centers of nanotechnology
your mission in Grenoble France saw the
National French lab has started this
mean attack may end up in Belgium is i
MEK which is a really big semiconductor
foundry and we've also got the one in
albany new york but it's kind of joint
between IBM and suny albany oh yeah from
your perspective how are these different
from each other uh what is sort of T
enanos kind of okay unique position in
the middle of all of it well i would say
three things one is that TN a no covers
all kinds of products line you know we
even could take care of MEMS and carbon
nanotubes and even the batteries
so it's it's a larger consortium then I
think the minitek or I make or even
elbow knee that's one thing and number
two I think it's similar to minitek
where it's it's a calm it's a
government-led program minitec is a very
concise city in a GU noble where you
have Lettie the dca organization and
also the university they're strongly
supporting the the activities so I think
it has somewhat resemblance with minitec
here imac although very popular it is
more on the driven by the IMA koso sher
itself i mean the the consortium of the
companies and also that i make itself
and rules the oh the rules of for
example IP delivery systems and I be you
know the membership is very important
and it's basically I'm it is past having
a leadership taking leadership all those
projects whereas TN a know if somebody a
group of people want to do something and
the government is going to fund and they
can do it here and also it's open for
open utilization which is not common in
many of the leavers the consortium if
they are not member of that consortium
those the blue stars those are power
semiconductor pond Scioscia a freedom is
very a vast it's basically driven DoD
Albany here it's basically IBM and New
York State University it's a huge
compound here but not quite sure how
much outside New York people can take
advantage of this
area state has a somewhat a restriction
I'm no I would say the restriction but
have favoritism over the nuke State
corporations etc okay one last question
yes is Tia nano an ongoing project or is
there a plan to cite the current funding
will stop after five years or ten years
or something as I said before it's
there's a midterm five years so it's
probably pretty soon forward yeah going
forward we will need ok we have a
midterm plan we'll see how this figure
will turn out within year or two and the
project's out on going there are long
term so we can't stop the Tiana
initiative when the projects are ongoing
so we can't just stop right away but as
I see more more projects are increasing
in numbers and so there is a tendency
that we will grow more yes okay thanks
let's open the floor Sean so those that
govern funding project what is the role
of here and help us and found a mechanic
who is cyber project to pursue in the
passive distribution decides what
project the project is basically funded
from the government unless the it's it's
a private one now the console and like a
atty pack is a private pro socha so t
pack itself makes decisions but
government funded project like i
mentioned some of the projects you've
seen 5+1 for example those are
government funded projects so the
defender controls the the money okay and
the members to be involved they will
consult
with various companies so things like
use of use of the lab how do you promise
a project compost is that funding agency
proposed that or from your history to
change it berries yes because up next is
basically proposal based where's methods
more like a top-down mechanism there's
one called first at the top 30
scientists selected by csdp the Council
of science technology policy so at the
30 top researchers in Japan from which I
think five were selected to utilize
tienen oh wow so the five of 26 top 30
projects yeah so so far tia nano has not
had to choose between project a and
project be in terms of you can use
thirty percent of the lab and exactly
can't you yes yes what TNA know is a is
a more like a platform itself where if
there's a funding there then then then
people can cut gather up and utilize the
facility and also our know-how
accumulated into that compound you see
and also the other than project I
mentioned about this open utilization
companies and researchers can come and
utilize our facilities and come and
utilize our know how you see this is I
think one of the way to cultivate more
you know participants and to have a new
possible candidates for our consul
member use that first come first served
no well well we you mean the utilization
yeah if you do a web application and you
apply for a particular time or something
hopefully we can do first come first
basis better we are starting off from
this November see how many customers are
coming oh that's right it starts at one
level one so okay good you know what why
are the Japanese government and other
police are now focusing on the nano
technologies I mean drinks are do they
in that space you need nanotechnology so
Oh exam so you're really thinking more
about like the five big national
projects from Nettie and the one big
national project from next how did the
Japanese government decide that those
were critical areas oh you mean the
choosing of the projects or why bother
with why bother with nanotechnology why
bother with nanotechnology is simple
because we have industry there and if
you look at the the global market share
of example materials see still the
Japanese are dominant in materials of
wafer process materials for assembly and
testing process we still have marketing
power and for example production
equipment we still have marketing pie in
the global market so Japanese industries
as a whole although semiconductors is
decreasing we still have the industry
base that can support the semiconductor
industry and in and in addition to that
as I said before the the greener I t is
a social requirement for our future USA
as our demographics becomes more aged
and as we need more energy for other
purposes you know greener green ICT is
something that its prerogative it's the
right word yeah it's a preoperative for
a Japanese society so it's it's a
government deciding that we need this
particular industry to stay and create
new value for future society that's
political reason thanks
I visited scuba quite a few years ago
and it was very impressed by that place
because you go that places almost looks
like Los Angeles then I know many
Japanese colleagues work in the
semiconductor ever so I asked them why
don't you years school they said the
well nobody wants to leave Tokyo and
scuba is too far mmm so do you still
have a problem to attract that real good
person come to the school hmm a good
point probably this slide explains a lot
see Tsukuba it's as I mentioned it's an
artificial city that the cabinet made a
decision to concentrate everybody here
now it used to be a three villages and
nothing here it's rural area and before
it scuba express was there there is no
railroad transportation to scuba till I
believe early two thousand early two
thousands yeah two thousand one one
thousand around yeah till then there was
only bus transportation only and people
had to you know what do you call
touching funny and oh you go and you
leave your family yeah living somewhere
oh yeah okay here yes yeah you see so
people the families would live in Tokyo
yeah children would go to Tokyo fans and
they would go out with work and school
home all right and it was difficult for
people living in Tokyo to commute to
scuba right now because of this Scoob
Express I commute although it takes two
hours for me it's painful still but it's
better than three hours or four hours
and and and along this Scoob Express
line there more houses quickly the
urbanization is happening in this area
the population is growing this area on a
long scoop
Express so people who working in scuba
buy houses along this to express line
which is convenient for commute within
30 minutes and you can also go to Tokyo
so you have more and more people coming
in to Tacuba from outside scuba
previously it was basically people
living in scuba so it's changing I think
there's also more things growing up
around scuba there used to be so
university of tokyo now has a big campus
and kashi wat yes it's hard way from
it's all along this line yeah tokyo
university has opened a huge campus here
at Casa which is about 20 minutes from
scuba city actually you first associate
the beginning of your presentation talk
about that for the Japanese
semiconductor industry and one of the
reasons you experience is the studio us
a way of doing bank soon I personally a
lot of quick decisions involving large
investment so how do you see that
problem being solved ah well the game
plan has changed as I mentioned you know
serious a4a current game plan with
modular devices it's not applicable and
fast decision for a large investment is
needed we're sooo the RSA is not not
really up to that but i think the serial
say the the integration of various
different kinds of technology is very
essential for R&D for new architectural
changes you know architectural
innovation you have a completely new set
of architect in you need to it's before
modulation more modularization i think
and that's the area that we are focusing
on okay it will become motorized later
perhaps but at this moment we will
create values with with this vertical
integration of different industry
players different techniques different
engineering and different value chain
from different value chain to come on to
this open hub and to create a new
architect this is what we're focusing as
a R&D center mr. concept yeah yeah cause
they're behind that yes and but for for
japanese semiconductor companies they
will need to restructure the companies
and away from sweet mellow safety no no
at the beginning they'll have a first
mover's advantage if they're in that
consortium you see clearly they'll have
more advantage than those company who
are not in that Cirie Ozzy process
because they know what's what's needed
the specification that would be neat
required now modularization we'll take
later down the road but the first movie
with an advantage is when when you're
there a dart and east phase and they
will get to know more or what's required
on the upper stream or downstream or
upstream of the technology that's where
it was a comment on this Sherman ok so
way back in the mid-1990s professor no
naka wrote a very famous book called the
knowledge creating company and it was
all about the flow of knowledge inside
japanese companies and why that made
them so competitively strong back in the
70s and 80s and there he distinguished
two kinds of knowledge explicit
knowledge that you could write down
codify and what he called what he calls
Cassie knowledge tacit knowledge thank
you that really was sort of what people
knew and it was because they were in the
same organization that they could
interact with each other away from the
surface and by being in proximity to
each other they could do a lot of
knowledge exchange and at the early
stages of a technology wave that kind of
frequent adjustment the iwasa are three
hace su dia hace is really adjustment it
is essential what happens as the
technology matures is standardizing once
it standardizes it becomes price
competition and so of course you
can't keep up the same old pattern of
knowledge flow it becomes too high a
transact transaction costs so what
they're doing is they're trying to
create a new place for people to come
from different companies for these
really early stage early in the
technology wave kind of areas where you
do need a lot of coordination and
adjustment and things that never reach
the surface the difference is that now
you've got people not from one company
but from different value chain race and
even from the government as well as a
university all involved in this process
if you put it in bad terms they're
throwing everybody at one rain think
what happened but they are doing
projects and getting projects done and
this atomic switch that you mentioned
was that done through t enano or was
that the diet is that for him that came
from parts of the ITN an institution
nibsy had the tummy bug okay so it
really is a new kind of approach to
doing things especially in Japan thank
you I look at the ITRs roadmap and I'm
really curious you have a sense of when
some of these advanced technologies will
actually become production worthy and
maybe replace current ones for instance
if you look at sea moss CMOS is pretty
quickly running out of how to bedroom
right Intel style for micro processors
and memory companies and one other
question I noticed you don't seem to
have on this a transition to where we
might switch photons instead of
switching electrons it looks like
everything in these projects is still
switching electrons any thoughts or
photos are we doing that I think I I
sort of sweet and skip the some of the
slides but that you know what else we
use the video instead we use the video
instead but there was a photon silicon
project um sorry I'm it should this one
yeah the right-hand side yeah this is
the this is the portion that we were
using it's on the the the 4 x 4 matrix
which for dynamic optical path and also
transmission with the silicon photonics
for low-power high speed so the photo
photo process is very important that
would decrease the power consumption and
also enlarges the speed we recognize
that and we we have several projects
with that photonics circum photonics and
your first question is that when i see
the change of this paradigm this is very
difficult question because so i'm not a
prophet myself but you can see that the
current trend of this more you know the
integration Moore's Law is I pretty much
the same a pair of that gameplay I think
whereas these new devices are
architectural II different like having a
memory and the as the CMOS being you
know intertwined and as see if there is
a upgrade in energy consumption so those
new devices if consent play you have
different kind of modules being created
yes now whether that comes when that
comes it depends on the the the effort
of the console sure that's why the
console included includes all different
kinds of value chain people because they
want to know what would it come as a
device that is so different from the
current game plan so that they can adapt
more to that getting a new you know
devices is thien amo are actively trying
to establish like an office to market
technologies that are being developed
there do you leave that to the user
hmm users being who well like these
national projects they each have their
own IP structure yeah they have enjoy
about it when you open it out what's
going to happen okay from November one
what what what happens within the core
so sure are normally the IP rules of
average console is like this I know no
day one sorry yeah this one okay the
average technology management within
console is that like this most
cooperation have their own in-house
capability you know R&D center
themselves and they they don't do rd a
for what they're doing outside you know
like the the open innovation they they
choose the the arena where they feel
very weak at but once the inventions of
made it will be brought back to the to
their own corporate R&D laboratories and
will be tested further simultaneously
and I Peru differ among the console but
usually IP is patented by most
contributed party but the member Oh
members have MFE status most favorite
entity status for implementation right
granted to all members so all members
can you you know simultaneously develop
utilizing that IP with the with the most
the cheapest price so what happens is
that in the console sure they do the rd
but it will not be to the end of the
product line still you do need to
reproduce and test various things
in-house they do that in house so it's
it's this you know environment of
in-house exhale and extramural and no
extra memory directly at open innovation
and in-house R&D you know going
simultaneously on hand in hand and how
you manage this you know the the
personal for example rotation or you
know how you manage the Alliance within
the pool so sure no more deeper Alliance
for example it's all depends on
corporate strategy yeah okay other
questions go ahead so um a bit going
back to city also if it's then you're
saying it is within the same company
then people feel very free to share
knowledge and ideas and in this case
it's not going to be the same because
you always have the IP issue I took are
you doing anything to address that to
encourage people to share or people just
realize that they cannot do everything
by themselves so they have to come to an
environment like this do to do a
high-end ecology when you're saying that
within the console what your suggestion
is some ways to encourage yeah do you do
anything to encourage free sharing of
knowledge by people from different
companies yeah within the console shut
up you see TN a no is a hit big under
one roof kind of con salsa but within
that there is segmentation of console
shell depending on the project and
depending on the aim and end products
there envisioning right now within those
groups segments those different console
sure they have their own rule and the
most average consortium rule is like
this and they they share their knowledge
their true yes they sometimes they bring
they bring in their own knowledge as a
common basket yes there are some
construction who does that and
there are some companies who want to
back off a little bit but want to have
some new inventions it's a corporate
strategy right and how much money you
put onto that console shop that's also
corporate strategy it depends on what
the corporate strategy is so basically
this TIR nan under this console a they
use those console for their own strategy
so it's it's necessary for corporate to
have clear strategy for rd and the
product in line end zone and what they
want to do accomplish if they have some
some envision then they will utilize
these consortia for their own profit
which they couldn't have done in-house
because they didn't have expertise at
the point I'd like to be adjusted that's
easily essentially what we have it you
develop a technology with multiple
company in the consortium who own the
intellectual property or who has the
right to use it each company has
different contribution like the semi
tech in Canada in Texas yeah so that I
think that's what your question is how
the interaction cop is being shared yeah
that's not really a TIR na no problem
that's more of a problem of the
individual research projects the big
national projects and it is it's
typically IP is granted some sort of the
most favored entity status will be given
to every investing remember the
consortium one reason this is not a
bigger problem is because most of this
is pre competitive research this is
research that's so early you'll get more
academic articles and you will patents
right but it is something that they will
let the individual users deal with IP
based on whatever that users consortium
yeah yeah you know is whatever their
stating con so she decides the ownership
of the IP invasion it's exactly as old
pattern in Japan it's been that way ever
since they started battle projects as
well so this is basically what's
different about this is tia now no
offers this platform yes that lets
people keep them right out any trust a
glee whereas imac for example they have
their own rules for a game plan that's
what i heard they don't let the pond
socha decide but they have their own
rules of the house that's probably
somewhat different from my mac and real
EU thing you think yes yes i think we're
going to have to close up the formal
part of the program i have one last
question we want to ask so japan is
under heavy government debt yeah even
worse than the u.s. is japan going to be
able to continue funding this kind of
advanced research hmm we want to as long
as Tess feo is willing to accept the
outcome I think it's its government and
also the the the tiered nano members
need to be aware of accountability to
the taxpayers now we need to bring out
the results and visible to the taxpayers
to show that the money is being utilized
and making progress in produces some of
them already products and came into
commercialized some still in process but
I think it is very critical for our
researchers and as an institution % well
the group per se to be more accountable
and to the taxpayers not to the
politicians only but also the older
individual taxpayers that this is
something that is for the future of the
country per se and not for the industry
well itself but for the society so as I
mentioned before it's ubiquitous green
and society this is something that we're
looking as a societal benefit and green
ICT is a crucial area element for that
we want to prove that as long as this
theory is being explored and being
explained
and being convinced i think the funding
would continue thank you it's great
session thank you very much thank you
you